they will face this guy we talked about
ronaldo lopez
those numbers at aaa we mentioned
earlier 10 starts is 7.62 but
nerd run average at just over two
here at the big league level 17th
appearance and his seventh start as he
nails the fastball strike three
to start the ball game he's david
fletcher
2-2 through that light blue sky into
center field and robert coasting in for
out number two
fletcher is retired that's two outs and
shohei ohtani will be the next batter
as he rips that one off sheets karim stu
hernandez who can't get it back to first
base in time it'll go as a rocket
infield single for shohei ohtani that
ball was hit very very hard
and got a little bit of luck on that one
too pick up an infield hit stassi
meanwhile a 257 hitter working out of
the four spot for the angels
strike three
lopez again paints with the fastball
ohtani stranded alex cobb back off the
shelf the wrist injury behind him making
his first start since july 23rd
and a chance for alex to at least finish
the season with some momentum when he's
been out there gooby he's been great for
the halo yeah they're expecting around
70 75 pitches today and anderson can
hold off a strikeout for alex cobb to
start the day here's jose abreu d.h
today
struck him out alex cobb with an
impressive one two three first first big
league inning in over two months ankles
have a base runner to start the inning
off and rendifo who's been picking up
his hitting a little bit he's had hits
in six of his last seven games
oh randhifa with a big swing and a
two-run dinger whispering heapo is going
to do some grooving now going around the
bases on that one that ball is crushed
we surrender giving the halos an early
two-nothing lead infield back down with
two strikes on long brother of colton
wong
lopez gets him looking
fastball frozen savannah's then sheets
and garcia here in the second
and jimenez is caught looking great run
on that pitch cobb's fastball is really
moving today runners at first and second
here's the next batter and this is ramy
gonzalez
that's up the middle it gets past cobb
right to fletch the double play midfield
hit for ohtani bouncer hit the bag at
first in the first
lopez strikes out ohtani's got five in
the early going two-nothing angels at
first base with one out is hernandez and
now tim anderson the leadoff man will be
the batter
that's bounced back up the middle what a
fine play by david fletcher who somehow
got it to wren he vote for the out clip
that one off and put it on the gold
glove reel just another reason to put
that in the mantle david fletcher
falling two strikes to count to louise
robert
and cobb strikes him out the angels are
cooking now with runners at first and
second and nobody out
[Music]
hot shot for anderson nobody's covering
for what would have been a double play
ball and everybody's safe
where was hernandez oh boy that was bad
and the angels now have the bases loaded
and jack mayfield will be the next
batter
mayfield sends the ball into the corner
that's a fair ball stassi scores easily
walsh will come in right behind him
they're going to try it with ren hifo
no play at the plate
a base is clearing double and now
mayfield's on his way to third as the
ball got away from collins
wow still nobody out for jose rojas
jose rojas with a drive out to right
when that one's gonna go and way out of
here
seven nothing angels
welcome back
jose rojas
single two run home run that's almost
jim tomy type territory jimenez and
sheets aboard with one away angel's up
7-0
and a bouncer for fletcher to wren heffo
and the relay in time to double him up
shohotani leads off the angels half of
the fifth
one hopped out to the rover and ohtani
beats it out second and third with
nobody out
a little flare out to shallow left field
and it's going to drop in front of
jimenez
ohtani will score an rbi single for
jared walsh eight nothing angels and now
the angels will have the bases loaded
mayfield rolls the ball out to shortstop
anderson to hernandez not in time for
the double play stassey scores
nine nothing halos
cesar
to tim he had to wait for it and he
pours it on for the double play four and
six and three and the innings over
nine zip middle five so marsha's on with
a one out single on one for fletcher on
the ground burst snares it was going to
cover it's hernandez and it's a double
play nifty one to four to three on the
twin killing and it brings up jose abreu
is hitting in the heart of the lineup
1-1
into right field
tim's coming home and the shutout's over
sox have their first run this afternoon
so now the aforementioned billy hamilton
will step up to the plate he came into
the game in right field for laori garcia
and hamilton pops up on the first pitch
stassey into the shadows hey makes the
catch and a tough chance at that
that's a great play by stassi remember
he got hurt at the big a on a similar
pop-up and the new pitcher for the white
sox is jose ruiz
strikes out ruiz fans of third error
charge to the sox and here's walsh
anderson down to an e again
and they cannot turn it as gonzalez's
throw a little late
looks like tim has a bead on it
and that'll do it
stretch time 9-1 angels jimmy herget
pitched yesterday he did not face tim
anderson we'll face him here with the
bases loaded and nobody out
got him oh man i mean you just made a
former batting champion look like he
couldn't see you at all see if luis
robert can be a difference maker with
the bases loaded and now one out in the
inning
[Applause]
everybody moves up one
little soft serve base hit it's nine to
two
they're still loaded and here comes jose
in the air to center this will get
collins home
marsh will make the grab
and his throw is going to go toward
third
and it's a sac fly for abreu his second
rbi today it's nine to three hurricanes
got what he wants
it was the slider and he strikes out
jimenez with it two runs but two left
stranded for the eighth a 9-3 angel lead
one last ride for ohtani here in front
of the chicago fans this year
yeah
following the strike
hey
dude
those are three brutal misses
they might run him
what's what's the deal here chris
conroy's coming that might be it
they might run him here
remember a number of the white sox
and tony will want an explanation for
sure he's starting to get a little more
animated and away he goes tony larussa
ejected
i think tony's asking where's the
warning
the chant is tony
six run game you're down to your last
out been a frustrating afternoon
frustrating series for the white sox and
500 is not up not a bad proposition
that's exactly what's happened
as the angels had split the eight-game
road trip through some stiff road
competition they've taken two out of
three on the road from a first place
team